- Good morning, everyone.
Glad to see you.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm Dean at the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
And I'm very happy to welcome
you to today's conference--
Intersections, Understanding
Urbanism in the Global Age.
As Harvard's Institute
for Advanced Study,
Radcliffe is charged
with a dual mission
to both foster and then to
share transformative ideas
across academic disciplines.
We do this by convening
and supporting scholars,
scientists, and artists
from around the world who
work together at the
forefront of their fields.
And we share this research with
a broad and interested public
through a full
calendar of events,
including lectures, conferences,
performances, and exhibitions.
All of Radcliffe's
events are made possible
by our supporters, many of
whom are here with us today.
Your generosity
allows us to continue
making lectures, exhibitions,
conferences, and other events
free and open to the public.
So thank you.
Today's Intersections
Conference is the culmination
of two ambitious initiatives.
First, here at Radcliffe
we choose a theme each year
to focus our programming
across the Institute.
This past year we
have explored urbanism
through a wide range
of events, including
lectures and seminars, poetry
readings and walking tours.
In addition to
serving as a capstone
to this year's
thematic programming,
this conference wraps up
a four year initiative
on interdisciplinary
urbanism at Harvard
supported by a very generous
grant from the Mellon
Foundation.
And this grant is
aimed at drawing
humanities and urban
studies closer together.
Radcliffe has collaborated with
the Graduate School of Design,
the Mahindra Humanities Center,
and the Arts and Humanities
Division of the Faculty
of Arts and Sciences
to host the Harvard Mellon
Initiative from its inception.
In addition to
public programming
like today's conference, the
Harvard Mellon Initiative
has produced new courses,
research projects,
digital platforms,
and publications.
A priority of the
Harvard Mellon Initiative
has been finding ways to bring
together the many faculty
and students across Harvard
who work on aspects of urbanism
but who are not in
communication with each other.
To help achieve
this goal, Radcliffe
has convened
faculty and students
through lectures, workshops,
and thematic dinners
to generate exciting new
intellectual connections
and we hope potential
collaborations
in urban study in the
future at Harvard.
Today's conference is
an opportunity for us
to consider together
the fundamental shifts
in the nature of urbanism on
a global scale that now affect
and concern us all.
Today 54% of the
world's population
lives in urban environments.
That is roughly
4.1 billion people.
And UNICEF estimates that
70% of the world's population
will be urban by 2050.
But understanding the
new global urbanism
requires more than statistics
on demographics, density,
and diversity.
At this conference we will probe
the way cities are experienced
by their inhabitants,
drawing out
the human in urban humanities,
to explore the challenges
and rewards that people
living in urban communities
face today.
To get this lived
experience, we will
call on a wide range
of tools of analysis,
ranging from new
media to big data.
Our presenters will share
multiple and creative
approaches to discerning
the complex set
of interrelationships,
personal and group identities,
change agents, and natural
and built environments that
shaped cityscapes and urban
life today and into the future.
As we dig deep into
the nature of urbanism
in the 21st century, it
will be important not
to overgeneralize and
assume that all cities are
created equal.
In the wake of the 2016
US presidential election,
we heard a lot about
the urban-rural divide
in the United States.
But the fate of American
cities is equally as diverse.
A few superstar
cities increasingly
dominate global networks of
finance and communication
while other cities
are left behind.
And even as the world
cities are increasingly
linked by networks of capital,
technology, and migration,
distinctions created by
local traditions of culture
still matter.
All of these issues must
be on our agenda for today.
What is more, each
city is itself divided.
Today cities
throughout the world
face what some experts have
called the new urban crisis.
More and more, the
affluent and the educated
flocked to cities,
which then spurs
rising prices and segregated
and unequal living conditions.
Amid this crisis urbanists
face complex challenges.
How can we preserve
the opportunity
that cities have traditionally
offered their residents
and newcomers?
How can we sustain any
broad based urban identity
when a city's people lead
highly segmented lives?
What are the instruments
of creating healthier, more
just cities when they operate
within an unpoliced world
of global capitalism and
international institutions?
The attractions of the new city
are also its Achilles heel.
And then, of course,
there are the challenges
raised by even larger forces,
including our planet's shifting
climate.
With so many great
cities originally
ports on oceans and rivers
including our own Boston,
sea rise is an imminent danger.
In addition, threats
to water, clean air,
and natural resources
destabilize our cities,
think Flint, Michigan, and add
another layer of complexity
to contemplating the future.
But there is hope, too.
Smart cities are
now using big data
to solve complex urban problems.
Experts in urbanism
are prioritizing
green infrastructure
and architecture.
Urban planners have
placed renewed emphasis
on making well-designed
human-scaled public space
accessible to all.
And citizens in
some cities are even
taking place making
into their own hands
to invent new ways to make
our cities more livable.
Clearly, the challenges
facing today's global urbanism
are complex, multi-layered,
and vast in scale.
Which is why I am so
glad we are welcoming
a wide range of speakers
to Radcliffe today
to reflect on the human
experience of urban living
from many angles.
Here's how the day will work.
We will open the conference
with a keynote address
by author Angela Flournoy.
And I will tell you a bit
more about Angela in a minute.
The panels that follow
will be moderated
by three scholars who have
directed the Harvard Mellon
Initiative.
The first panel, Ways
of Knowing the City,
will explore the
experiential sensory
and most human aspects of
urbanism made accessible to us
through a wide variety of media.
It will be moderated by Julie
Buckler, the Samuel Hazard
Cross Professor of Slavic
Languages and Literatures
and of Comparative Literature
who is also the Faculty
Director of the Humanities
here at Radcliffe
and the Coprincipal Investigator
of the Harvard Mellon
Initiative.
The second panel is entitled,
Beyond the Nature/Technology
Divide.
And it will examine the
evolving relationship
between the technology
of urban infrastructure
and new notions of nature
and landscape design
that challenge this
traditional opposition.
Eric Ghenoiu, the initiative's
research program manager,
will moderate this panel.
The third panel is
entitled Plan an Unplanned,
which could also be thought
of as formal and informal.
This panel will highlight the
spontaneous, the grass roots,
and how even the
best of urban plans
can evolve in surprising
and refreshing directions.
Yves Blau, Adjunct
Professor of the History
and Theory of Urban
Form and Design
at the Graduate School of
Design and the other Coprincipal
Investigator of the
Harvard Mellon Initiative,
will moderate this panel.
And after the keynote
and after each panel
we will open the floor
to your questions.
We'll place a microphone
in the center aisle.
If you have a question, please
line up, identify yourself,
and ask your question.
And at the end of
the conference,
I hope you will all join us for
a reception in the Sheerr room
of Fay house just next door.
It's now my great pleasure
to introduce today's
keynote speaker Angela Flournoy.
Angela's an award
winning writer whose
work has appeared in The
Paris Review, The New York
Times, and The New Republic,
among many other places.
She's a graduate of the
Iowa Writer's Workshop.
And she is the author of the
acclaimed novel The Turner
House, which was a finalist
for the National Book Award.
We asked Angela to keynote our
conference because her fiction
probes deeply into the human
experience of living in cities.
The Turner House explores
the lives of the large Turner
family in Detroit
for more than half
a century after Frances Turner
journeyed there from Arkansas
during World War II.
Angela is currently
working on a novel that
traces the lives of a group
of African American women
in Los Angeles
and New York City.
And I think and hope we will
hear more about that today.
Please join me in giving a warm
welcome to Angela Flournoy.
- Hi everyone.
I'm honored to be
here this morning.
Thank you Liz for that
flattering introduction.
And thank you to
everyone at the Radcliffe
Institute for organizing
today's conference.
When you write a novel that is
about something, whether it's
politics, history,
or even ghosts,
you might from time
to time be asked
to speak about these
subjects on the assumption
that in order to write
about them in your fiction
you must actually know
a great deal about them.
The reality is is
that we fiction
writers get by on a passing
knowledge of most topics.
Just what it takes to convince
the reader of continuity
in our make-believe story lines.
We learn enough about a field
of medicine for a character
to convincingly practice it.
Or about a trend
in 1940s women's
wear to compel the
reader to imagine it.
Expertise is rarely achieved.
I'm happy to report
that today is not one
when I find myself
having to beef up
a fleeting interest
in a topic in order
to pass as knowledgeable
in front of all of you.
Urbanism is something I think
about often for many reasons
in many different ways.
My interest in the phenomenon
has artistic as well as
professional and personal roots.
I hope that by sharing some
of my thoughts on urbanism
and how these thoughts
influence my work as a novelist,
I might be able to
spur a conversation
or at least keep you
awake at this early hour.
First a confession,
my own origins
are not particularly urban.
Or rather they
were at the onset.
I was born in Los Angeles and
lived in what people broadly
call South Los Angeles for
the early years of my life.
But my life subsequently
became suburban.
I feel as if I have to get
that fact out in the beginning
as people are prickly about
the origins of writers
who talk of the cities.
I write about big
cities, yet I hail
from West Covina, California
a city in Los Angeles
County with a mere 100,000
residents and enough cul de
sacs to seriously hinder
horseback invasion.
Still this wasn't a homogeneous
existence most conjure
up when thinking of suburbs.
It worked.
West Covina is an ethnoburb,
one of many in the San Gabriel
Valley, populated by
predominantly Latino and Asian
American families.
My neighborhood sat in
a corner between Walnut,
an affluent,
predominantly Chinese
American and Filipino town and
La Puente, a working class,
largely Mexican American city.
I had friends who rode
horseback on trails in Walnut
on weekends and friends who
lived in section 8 housing
across the street from
my apartment complex.
I watched films about the
shortcomings of urban life
and had the sensation
of both identifying
with some of those ills,
the outdated textbooks,
and overcrowded classrooms,
and the gang violence,
the teen pregnancy, the
uneasy race relations.
And understanding
that we were living
in the place that was
supposed to be better
off than these city centers.
We were supposed
to be the escape.
Indeed, my own mother
had moved to West Covina
for this purpose.
I did not identify
with pop culture
and literary representations
of suburban life.
I had a single mother.
We lived in apartments,
the suburbs,
from The Wonder
Years to Full House,
all the way back
to Updike's Rabbit,
Run were presented
as outside of time,
without a distinctive sound,
save for the opening of garage
doors and devoid
of all odors save
for the smell of
cut grass, barbecue
smoke, and hot asphalt.
We had smells and sounds
a plenty in West Covina.
At the time 30% of the city's
population was foreign born.
I was in bilingual
English Spanish classes
until fourth grade when
the state of California
stopped funding
bilingual education.
There wasn't an easy category
for our city at the time.
We were 30 years too early
to the browning of America.
Something that I
only recently learned
might ruin this country if
it is allowed to transpire.
But none of us felt ruined.
I concluded that the
word urban is slippery.
It didn't translate depending
on where in this country
one lived.
And like all
language, its meaning
was determined by the
person employing It.
For instance, the
city of Compton
is another Los Angeles
County satellite
with fewer than 100,000
residents, a decades old
equestrian club, and more
tall elegant palm trees
than West Covina
could ever yield.
Yet few would argue with
Compton's categorization
as urban, especially not
in the '80s and '90s.
This is perhaps because
of its elevated crime
rate or the efforts of
rappers Dr. Dre and the group
NWA to put the small city
on the national stage.
But more likely, its
due to the heavily Black
population of Compton
during those years.
Until the late aughts,
urban in this country
was a well-worn euphemism for
Black and often poor and Black.
It was handier than
ethnic, because on its face
it wasn't about race, and more
flexible than inner city, which
suffered from being
overly specific.
The Oxford English
Dictionary still
offers a secondary
definition of urban
that is simply denoting Black
popular culture in general.
Urban adult and contemporary is
used by the Recording Industry
Academy of America as
a catch-all category
for music made by
or for Black folks
that isn't hip hop or gospel.
But times change and words
mutate at an astonishing rate.
Today the word urban
may just as easily
conjure images of
gleaming high-rises,
minimalist coffee boutiques,
co-working spaces,
and a man walking 12
dogs at once for pay.
The dog walker trope
is so prevalent,
it has graced the
cover of The New Yorker
more than once over
the past decade.
And by affixing "ism" to
the end of the word urban,
we move from talking
about people all together
to talking about trends and
data and fields of study.
The definitions have shifted.
But some people did
not get this memo.
You're living in poverty.
You have no jobs.
58% of your youth is unemployed.
What the hell do
you have to lose?
This was Donald
Trump on the campaign
trail in Detroit in October.
When Trump referred
to urban centers,
he employed the old codes,
which offended many urbanites
sensibilities.
It was like he hopped
out of a DeLorean
from a bygone decade
sporting a wide tie
and using the wrong language.
Didn't he know that urban
meant something different now?
Apparently not.
So confident was he in the
inextricable relationship
of Black folks to urban
spaces, spaces mired in misery,
that he nominated
an unqualified man
to run the Department of
Housing and Urban Development
by virtue of his
blackness alone.
It is one of the
more absurd cases
of coded language influencing
actual decision making.
For literature, the word urban
and the concept of urbanism
has just as many faces.
I'm proud to say that I am
a writer of the urban novel.
This is not to be confused
with urban fiction, which
in the book-selling world is
used to categorize those page
turners by African Americans.
From Iceberg Slim to
Sister Souljah that
focus on the violence, sex,
and fast money of street life,
the urban novel is a
literary tradition more
than a hard and fast genre.
These are narratives that
make it their mission
to analyze what it is like to
be a single person or a network
of people in a large system
of housing, transportation,
and industry.
There are many reasons
to write an urban novel.
City residents have an
increased probability
of encountering a stranger
or the downright strange.
They may experience
the dissonance
of turning off a well to do
block onto an alleyway mired
in poverty.
And what's more,
they may come to see
this juxtaposition as normal.
Their lives are impacted by
street corner policing and city
hall politics.
The standard fare claustrophobia
of apartment living
can morph into
paranoid agoraphobia
during times of
political upheaval.
Neighbors can become threats
to one's existence overnight.
It follows then that characters
who dwell in cities both real
and imagined often have
concerns and desires that
differ from those who
dwell outside of them.
And through the preoccupations
of a novel's characters,
we might get a window into the
underlying concerns of a city's
real life residents.
A person may never have a chance
to visit Mexico City or Delhi
or Tokyo but they may read
fiction by Roberto Belano,
Karan Mahajan or Haruki Murakami
that helps them understand
something about those cities
that guidebooks and historical
texts cannot, the psychological
essence of a place.
When readers say the city
feels like a character,
as they often say to me in
a work of fiction, what they
really mean is the
characters' lives
are so connected to the city
that the more I know them,
the more I know it.
I'm interested in how
writers accomplish this.
How urban settings impact
characters psyches' and how
these settings influence
a story structure.
Rarely is an urban novel
described as quiet.
We employ that adjective when
talking about stories where not
much happens on a plot
level but emotional shifts
are afoot that keep us
reading nonetheless.
Quiet is most often the realm
of the country or the cookie
cutter suburb.
These places are more likely
to have controlled exterior
environments, whether
it's because your nearest
neighbor is miles away or you
live in a bedroom community.
In such settings the character
might experience a change
to their exterior worlds
gradually, perhaps
at the pace of an
entire lifetime.
Barring those novels
where a character
lives in an urban space
but seldom ventures outside
of their home or outside
of their own memories,
its very difficult for an urban
novel to remain quiet for long.
Change can be swift
and life altering.
A character's only window
is blocked off by a newer
construction next door.
A pickpocket steals
the love letter
that an aging man had finally
mustered up the courage
to deliver to his paramour.
Each interaction on the
street, in the grocery store,
at a concert, is an
opportunity for intersection,
for one reality to
collide with another.
Such collisions can
drive the plot forward.
These unplanned
interactions are also
why the urban
novel, at its core,
is one that must grapple
with multiple types of change
at once.
Over the last
century, novels have
helped shape our
associations with urbanism
as a catalyst for
change, as a sensibility,
and as a sociological
phenomenon.
In the early industrial
years of the 19th century,
Charles Dickens via the travails
of Oliver Twist, the Dorrit
family, and others, highlighted
the inequalities of life
in London under an
indifferent capitalist system.
The moral lines were
more or less clear.
And readers were
encouraged to consider
how this new leap
into industry was
changing their sensibilities.
There's a through line from
Dickens to the muckraker
Upton Sinclair, who used a
heavier hand in his novel
The Jungle but with a similar
focus on how modernity might
be leaving so many behind.
At the turn of the
century in this country,
two novels exemplify the
questions American urban novels
would continue to grapple with
into the post-industrial era.
What do we sacrifice by
moving into urban spaces
and who do we become?
Theodore Dreiser's Sister
Carrie published in 1900
is the story of one
woman's coming of age
as well as the story
of a man's undoing.
Carrie, bright, timid, and full
of the illusions of ignorance
in youth, as Dreiser writes,
escapes her humdrum town
in Wisconsin by
migrating to Chicago
to live with her sister.
She soon finds her
sister and brother
in law's flat full
of joyless toil
and takes up with a dandy
who clothes and houses her
as his mistress.
After another illicit romance
and a brief escape to Montreal,
Carrie lands in New York.
By the novels end,
she gains a measure
of independence and acclaim
in New York theater.
But she isn't
necessarily any happier.
Throughout the novel,
Dreiser takes care
to make connections
between the changes
afoot in the urban spaces Carrie
inhabits and those nascent
within Carrie herself.
He describes 1889 Chicago
as a city of over 500,000
with the ambition, the
daring, and the activity
of a metropolis of a million.
Carrie is similarly brimming
with ambition that surpasses
her age, gender, and station.
This is an additional
charge of urban novelists,
to find ways to fold
impertinent city
data and historical
information into the storyline
without lapsing
into the academic.
No offense to all
of you academics.
Dreiser presents the city
as a place of lax morality,
particularly for
single women, but also
a place for self actualization.
And he accomplishes this via
a starker form of realism
than the literary world at
the time thought appropriate.
The book was panned
and then rediscovered
and celebrated
several years later.
Sister Carrie, with
its depiction of class
jumping, bed hopping,
and generally doing
what it takes to make it
in the 20th century city,
is the forebearer of a
particular and persistent
strain of American urban novels,
from F. Scott Fitzgerald's
The Great Gatsby to Claire
Messud's The Emperor's
Children.
I even stumbled upon a
quiz online the other day
which asks readers
to differentiate
between the words of sister
Carrie and those of Sex
and the City's Carrie Bradshaw
and it is very, very difficult
to do.
Meanwhile, The Sport of the
Gods, Paul Laurence Dunbar's
1902 novel tackled the impact
of the shift to urban living
on the ultimate
outsider, the low income,
rural, southern African
American family.
After Berry, the patriarch
of the Hamilton family
is wrongfully
convicted of robbing
his white boss, the remaining
family flees to New York.
The Hamiltons imagine the city
similar to how Dreiser's Sister
Carrie imagines it.
They had heard of New
York as a place vague
and far away, Dunbar writes.
A city that like
heaven to them had
existed by faith alone all
the days of their lives
they had heard of it.
And it seemed to them the
entire of all the glory,
all the wealth, and all
the freedom of the world.
The Hamiltons take
a train north.
They inquire about
the boarding house
at the depot when they arrive.
And they make their
way bit by bit.
They ultimately
find that the North
can be just as inhospitable
to Blacks as the South.
And their disillusionment
is bitter and permanent.
But before that, Dunbar gives us
a perfect poetic encapsulation
of the newly minted
city slickers burden.
After it is all
over, after he has
passed through the first
pangs of strangeness
and homesickness,
yes, even after he
has got beyond the stranger's
enthusiasm for the metropolis,
the real fever of
love for the place
will begin to take
hold upon him.
The subtle insidious
whine of New York
will begin to intoxicate him.
Then if he be wise, he
will go away, any place,
yes, even over to New Jersey.
But if he be a fool,
he will stay and stay
until the town becomes
all in all to him,
until the very streets are his
chums and certain buildings
and corners his best friends.
Then he is hopeless.
And to live elsewhere
would be death.
The Barrow will be his
romance, Broadway his lyric,
and the park his pastoral.
The river and the glory
of it all, his epic.
And he will look down pityingly
on all the rest of humanity.
I myself try not to be that
sort of navel gazing urbanite.
But it's hard sometimes.
Battered and broken by
the city, the Hamiltons
moved back South, thereby making
the novel a tenuous early entry
into what would become the canon
of great migration literature
and art.
In urban novels that encompass
this period of migration,
the typical changes
afoot in a city
are compounded by
the changes tied
to the precarious relationship
of Black characters
to White characters.
For Black characters
without the ability
to pass as White, as Nella
Larsen's character sometimes
do, class ascension and true
assimilation are distant goals.
Survival comes first.
And just when that
bar is cleared,
another might be raised.
The city is an imperfect
refuge in these works of art.
From Richard Wright's Native Son
Lorraine Hansberry's A Raisin
in the Sun, a place where
one might comfortably
be a little bit more
their truer self but
where the price of
such freedom is often
backbreaking work and sometimes
a forfeiture of dignity,
and, yes, even sanity.
My first novel The Turner House
is a great migration novel.
This is because I had no choice.
I didn't set out to write
a great migration novel.
The more I learned about
the city of Detroit,
the more it became
clear that a core issue
was how the city, both
individuals and leadership,
refused to welcome migrants
from the South, first by denying
them housing for as long
as possible then fleeing
the city altogether rather
than co-habitate with them.
It's an old story, but
it feels quite fresh
when I read about politicians
across the country attempting
to prevent this or
that sort of migrant
from establishing a toehold
in their cities and towns.
Today we live in a time of
big cities as generations
before us have lived.
But we're also
living in a period
of unusual change in regards
to what it means to be urban.
Now the issue
isn't so much, what
do we lose by migrating
from small town to large.
But it centers on
what we lose or how
we change by other sorts
of movement in relation
to urban life; like
forced migration
to cities and new countries due
to conflict, drought, rising
sea levels, or a search
for economic opportunity;
migration out of cities
to the surrounding
suburbs due to a scarcity
of affordable housing;
the increasing
role of technology
in influencing housing
markets, state surveillance,
and patterns of movement.
How will cities welcome us.
How can we manage to continue
to live in the cities
that we know and love?
Who is the city for?
For my own work, I come
back to the idea of change
itself as a useful vehicle
for getting stories going
and for engaging my reader.
As a descendant of the
great migration who grew up
in a town full of
recent immigrants,
I can't help but think that
conversations about urbanism
must continue to include
a discussion of migration,
inclusion, and
shifting identities,
which brings me to the novel
I'm currently working on.
This is currently
on my cork board.
"The act of migration puts
into crisis everything
about the migrating
individual or group,
everything about
identity and selfhood
and culture and belief.
So if this is a novel
about migration,
it must be the act of
putting in question.
It must perform the
crisis it describes."
Salman Rushdie was referring
to his own novel The Satanic
Verses.
For my next novel I'm interested
in where black people live
in the city and where
they migrated from
and where they appear
to be moving to next.
In his November 2014 article,
"The Suburbs, Not Just for
White People Anymore"
in The New Republic,
William H. Frey reports that in
the first decades of the 2000s,
the central cities of the 100
largest metropolitan areas
saw a total decline
of 300,000 blacks,
the first absolute
population decrease
among blacks for these
cities as a group.
Black folks are on the
move in ways they haven't
been since the great migration.
Some back South, like Dunbar's
Hamilton family, perhaps
completing a 100 year loop.
Some further away from city
centers to suburbs and exurbs
that were previously the
providence of middle class
and working class whites.
The rest of the
country is beginning
to get a taste of the
ethnoburbs of my youth.
Except they are not being
formed as places of refuge
from city life, so much as
communities of necessity.
My second novel takes
place mostly in Los Angeles
and follows a group of
African American women,
as Liz pointed out,
from 2015 to 2035.
And they begin at 30 years old
and at the end of the novel
they will be in their 50s.
I've been thinking about
both the spatial changes that
are already underway, what
Los Angeles looks like,
as well as the demographic
changes, who lives where,
and the cultural
ones-- how do we live?
What are we preoccupied with?
What will be the
quinoa of the future
that we'll all be
begrudgingly eating?
I'm not a science
fiction writer.
So the first thing I decided
was to make some parameters
for myself and for the reader
to manage their expectations.
One reason I chose the
age span that I chose
is because, with the
exception of one character,
I don't envision these women
as early adopters of radically
new technology into their 50s.
This means that I do not intend
to wade too far into the waters
of technological speculation.
People might be letting Google
or its parent company Alphabet
implant chips into
their brains by 2035,
but none of my characters
will be lining up
for such a procedure.
They will however
probably be willing to be
driven in self-driving cards.
I plan to depict incremental
shifts rather than
drastic ones.
So I really think
of this project
in terms of several periods
of change instead of one
leap from now into the future.
For the spatial changes I'm
focusing on the transportation
and housing broadly.
And so far I've spent
most of my time thinking
about Los Angeles
in this respect.
In order to think about
our present moment
as well as to
imagine future ones,
I start my research in the past.
The story of Black and
Latino life in Los Angeles
has been tied to the
story of transportation
in the city for some time.
As is the story of every
category of Angeleno.
The 10 and 60 freeways bisected
the Latino communities east
of downtown, creating
new neighborhoods
and irreparably altering
the dynamic of old ones.
So this is, they are
building the freeway here.
And these neighborhoods
here, parts
of East LA that
basically just were
decimated by the
construction of the freeway.
The extension of the harbor
freeway south to San Pedro
decimated the Central Avenue
African American business
district in a way that
made my grandfather bitter
when he talked about
it, even into his 80s.
But fiction obsessed
person that I
am, hearing my grandfather
reminisce about the area
did not do much to
cement it in my mind
as reading Chester Himes' urban
novel If He Hollers Let Him Go.
Wherein in the main
character speeds
up and down central
avenue for night life,
for sex, and to
escape police pursuit.
So here you have the Colosseum.
And this is USC, my Alma mater.
And right here where the 110
freeway extension is happening,
and this is where it's not
complete, right behind the 110
is Central Avenue.
And Central Avenue
used to be home
to a wide variety of African
American businesses including
hotels.
And really in the city,
after those hotels went away,
there was a period of time
where it was very difficult
if you were not a
well-to-do black person
to find some place
where you could stay.
And this is
something that is not
unusual in other parts of
the country as we all know.
One of the things that compelled
me to make my first novel
The Turner House broader--
I thought it was just going
to be set in the present day--
was that the more that I learned
about these past neighborhoods,
these neighborhoods that
really fostered African
American self-reliance and
trade and community, that they
were the first things that were
decimated when the city decided
that for urban renewal
to add new parks,
like Lafayette Park in
Detroit, or new freeways.
And they basically
just went down
the middle of those
neighborhoods.
And one thing that
happens is that even
though a city will continue
and the black population will
migrate away from
those neighborhoods
and build new communities,
they never forget.
It's something that my
grandfather never forgot.
He never forgot Central Avenue.
And it changed the way that he
felt as a member of the city
altogether.
So even though the city
helped kill central avenue,
I mean excuse me, even
though the freeways
helped kill central
avenue, the freeways also
made it easier for people
living in segregated pockets
of the city to explore
other neighborhoods,
facilitating the movement
of new waves of Black
and Latino migrants further
east into the San Gabriel
Valley, where I grew up.
And into the Inland Empire
and north into the San
Fernando Valley.
I think about these
past changes and how
they impacted individual
movement, collective gathering,
and culture.
For the first four decades
of the 20th century
LA was crisscrossed
with streetcars, as were
many cities in the country.
Track miles peaked
in LA around 1925.
And ridership peaked during
World War II, in large part
due to gas and rubber rationing
as well as war industry
employment.
By the late '40s the street cars
were replaced with bus lines
with the exception
of a few lines that
became the basis of the
LA Metrolink system.
This is the current
LA metro system.
So if you go back
here and look at this
as more than one system.
This is three systems
overlapping, maybe more,
these dotted lines here.
And basically, a
streetcar went down all
of the main arteries
of Los Angeles.
And that means that there
was an affordable option
for most people to venture
out into parts of the county,
really.
Because they went all the way to
Pasadena and down to South Gate
that otherwise they
wouldn't have access to.
So when those lines
were inactive,
this is what we were
left with, which
if you compare it to before,
basically at most places
where black people live
or Latino people live,
they have to drive to get there.
And they are geographically
separated from other parts
of the city.
So it's a clear
inhibitor to integration.
So you end up with these
really homogeneous areas all
over the metro area.
So one thing that I'm
excited for in the future
is the Crenshaw LAX
line which is currently
underway in Los Angeles.
It's expected to be
complete in 2019.
More than the Expo line, which
recently opened and connected
downtown to Santa
Monica beach, I've
been actually anxiously
awaiting this extension
because what it will mean
for tens of thousands
of Black Angelenos
and Latino Angelenos.
So this is like a
zoomed in, this is just
a portion of the map
that I showed you before.
But this is a
predominantly Black part
of LA, which if anyone
is familiar with LA,
it's not all really LA.
It's other small cities as well.
Culver City is its own city.
Englewood is its own city.
But this is what
people generally
are thinking about when
they refer to South Los
Angeles, which is kind of a
new handy euphemism of where
the brown people live.
And right now there is
no connector between,
this is the new expo
line that takes you west.
It takes you from downtown
where more affluent people are
starting to live and USC is.
It takes you straight
through these neighborhoods
out to the beach.
But it really doesn't provide
any way for these neighborhoods
to communicate and
travel within themselves.
And so this Crenshaw line--
which in the short term
has displaced businesses
on Crenshaw Boulevard,
which is one
of the African American
business centers in the city--
long term, I'm interested to see
how it will affect where people
live, where people shop--
because right now you
don't really shop in
this part of the city,
you have to go
elsewhere to shop--
and who lives there.
And I'm also
interested to see how
that changes the
demographics of these areas.
So for instance, Baldwin
Hills and Ladera Heights,
they are intentionally
segregated.
These are upper middle class
African American enclaves.
They're not necessarily
interested in lower
middle class or
working class African
American having easy access
to their neighborhoods.
So that is one change
that is outside of just--
when we think about
justification,
we often think about
people of means
getting access or
having their eyes
opened to the neighborhoods
that they otherwise
wouldn't have found desirable.
But the reverse is
also possible where
you have people of means who
one of the things that they have
enjoyed is a geographical
separation from people
with less money than them
is one of the reasons why
during the riots these
neighborhoods were relatively
unscathed.
Because they were on hills.
And they were above.
And they were separate.
There was no easy
transportation to get there.
How that might impact the way
that these communities grow
and change, especially
as these populations age
that own these homes here.
If you would have told me 10
years ago that there might
be a future Los Angeles without
heavy dependency on freeways
and automobiles, I
wouldn't have believed you.
And I still kind of don't.
But I've come across a few
proposed projects that made
me think it might be possible.
Park 101 is a
proposed freeway cap
that would connect the north
and south sections of downtown
to either side of the 101.
So basically if you
remember the first slide
I showed which was the
10 freeway and the 101
freeway bisecting these
traditionally Latino
communities East LA.
Park 101 would restore a lot
of what was geographically
broken up 60 years ago.
Of course these
populations in this area
are not necessarily--
will they still are,
but they're quickly sort of
changing-- as predominantly
Latino as they once were.
But it's interesting
to see now how
a lot of the same things
that were considered
in the public good and
part of urban renewal
are now being reversed
in one way or the other,
whether that is the
metro lines returning
or whether that is physically
building land where the land
was purposefully taken away.
There have been many
projects proposed
to restore the LA
river and making
it a recreational destination.
People kayak in the
LA river, I would not.
But perhaps in the future
my characters will.
The California
high speed rail is
expected to be completed by 2029
barring governmental impediment
and will connect LA to the
Bay Area in 2 and 1/2 hours.
Many of these projects
focus on downtown.
But one that I am
particularly interested in
is the city of champions,
Englewood new sports
and entertainment complex at
the former Hollywood Bowl site,
excuse me, the
Hollywood Park site,
which will house the LA Rams and
the San Diego Chargers in 2019.
So this area here, this is not
something that is proposed.
This is something that is
actually happening right now.
The Rams are playing
in the Colosseum
and the poor Chargers are going
to be playing in the Home Depot
center in Carson, which
only has 30,000 seats.
But when this is built,
this will completely
change Englewood, which is
another similar to Compton.
A city that people consider
urban but is actually a suburb.
It has about 100,000 residents
and detached single family
homes.
But it is a
neighborhood that has
had experienced
economic depression
since the moving of the
LA Lakers from the Forum
to the Staples Center, even
though the Forum is now
reopened as an
entertainment space.
And so this will provide
revitalization to the area.
But a question is,
who will it benefit?
I grew up right around,
its hard to tell here,
but I believe that
prairie is over here.
I grew up right over
here off of prairie
before I moved to West Covina.
And I have friends who own
homes around that area.
And so the question
is, will they
feel that they are part
of this new development?
Or will they feel like this
new development is a new sort
of pressure to leave the area?
There's also proposed
redevelopment
of the Jordan Downs housing
projects in the works
to turn the area
into a mixed use
residential, commercial
district, which
comes with a host of
concerns about the future
of public housing in
LA and the likelihood
of sustained,
affordable housing.
What novels can do
is help us imagine
how changes like the ones I've
outlined feel on the ground.
In this moment of
partisan flame wars,
potential cuts to public
funding, unaddressed housing
shortages, and serious
environmental concerns,
simply imagining can seem
an unproductive luxury.
But it isn't.
It wasn't in the time of
Dickens or Dreiser or Dunbar.
And it is isn't today.
Urban spaces themselves
are the result
of people imagining
systems by which
they might be able to pool
resources, exchange goods,
and create communities.
If the imaginations
of human beings
brought urbanism
to life, then it's
worthwhile to imagine
how they might get better
serve us in the future.
Thank you.
- Hi, everybody.
I want to thank Angela for that
wonderful talk which opened up
so many rich themes that we'll
explore in more detail today.
Angela I think is willing
to entertain questions
from the floor.
So if you'd like
to ask a question,
please approach the
central mic in the aisle.
And when it's your turn
please identify yourself.
And please ask a question.
Don't just simply
make a comment.
And although we
welcome your comments.
So if you're interested
in asking questions
please approach the mic.
- Thank you so much Angela.
I am [INAUDIBLE] Tagiri,
a visitor from India.
In this deep engagement with
city, history, and personhood
self.
One of the things that I wish
to offer to think further
is the issue memory
with your grandfather.
But also memory vis-a-vis
not only the human loss,
but it's also the
connected, ecological loss.
For example, is there
tear for the dead river?
And so it is in
that spirit I just
choose to offer this theme to
think farther about the city
space as not only the
space for the human
but also it is a
living ecosystem.
It is in this space
your reference
to the dog walking people,
what is the place of dog,
for example, in the
nested ecosystem.
And how do we imagine the
city, not only for the human
being a kind of an
anthropocentric justice,
but how do we think of this city
in a post anthropocentric way.
- Thank you.
I think that that is one
challenge of growing up
in a smog laden,
drought ridden place
is that I sometimes don't think
about living things outside
of succulents and spiders
as much as I should.
But that is a very
important point
and it absolutely
relates to memory.
My grandfather grew
up in Louisiana
before he migrated
to Los Angeles.
And he always had
a garden, which
was not unusual with a lot of
first generation participants
in the great migration from
the South to the North.
My grandmother in Detroit
also had a garden.
And that was not just part
of their early upbringing
and subsistence, it was
part of community building.
And it was part of
like homesteading.
It is just what you
did, you had a garden.
And that is something that
especially over the drought
that everyone in LA thinks that
it's over but it's not over.
In the past five years
of extreme drought in LA,
that is something that has
just not been possible.
And what are the repercussions
of that culturally as well
as personally and economically.
- I'm Peggy [INAUDIBLE],
from Boston,
and I do have a question.
But I want to thank you
for your novel, which
is phenomenal, the first one.
- Thank you.
- I'm wondering what
your thoughts are
on privatization of public
space and public institutions
in this city.
That's my question.
And it's happening all
over, but in Boston
with who's buying
luxury apartments, who's
building privately
owned charter schools,
where they're being built.
In areas in Boston there's
intense conflict right now in
the southern part of the city
in Mattapan where there was
redlining and keeping blacks
out.
Then the banks
redlined and allowed
blacks to buy homes only
in that neighborhood.
And now there's a rich
immigrant community.
But it's the blackest
section of Boston
and that's where they're
closing a public school.
- There are so many
kind of like far
reaching implications
of privatization
of public property,
infrastructure, et cetera.
If you think about what has
happened in Flint, Michigan,
part of the problem
there is when
you have people who are not
scientists being the people who
get to make a decision about
what happens to the water
supply in a city.
And then they decide to
ignore the scientists.
Because it is more profitable
or more affordable to divert
the water from somewhere else.
A place that is not, it's
not safe for the residents.
So if you can
extrapolate that instance
into all of the different
ways that the interests
of private industry might not
be the same as the interests
of like the public good.
I don't like to generally
talk in slippery slopes
but a lot of bad
things could happen.
So that is I think
something that whether that
is in education or it's
something that in Southern
California is
always a hot topic,
whether that has to
do with our beaches
our state beaches which we
have miles and miles of miles
of that people are always
trying to get a referendum
on a local ballot to change.
What does that mean
for future generations?
That is something that we
all have to think about.
And we all have to
vote accordingly
to the conclusions we come to.
Because it is something that
is really under fire right now.
- My name is Joseph Greenberg.
I'm a graduate of the college
and a native of Cambridge.
And I was particularly
struck by the question
that you ended with, with
regards to development,
whether or not
existing residents feel
a part of new developments or
if they feel excluded by it.
My question is really
how do cities engage
with the people who will be most
impacted by the decision making
process that are usually
excluded from it.
For example, I was at the
Cambridge Board of this Zoning
Appeals hearing last night and
I was the youngest person there.
The crowd skewed very
older and whiter.
And it just seems to me that
decisions at this kind of level
are being made without
input from the people who
will be most affected by it.
So how do cities facilitate
a more inclusive conversation
around new developments.
- That's a very good
question Joseph.
So I think there's
like a quick answer
and there's a long answer.
So the quick answer
is just do better.
If it's your job to get
people to come to a thing,
whether you're a party
promoter or you're
putting on a
conference, you need
to figure out how to reach the
people that need to be there.
And so for them to
say, well, we posted it
in the community newsletter and
that was that, it is your job.
If that is what your charge
is, to engage that community,
you need to figure out how
to engage that community.
And the long answer
is that also it
has so much to do with
so many levels of just
institutionalized exclusion.
So if you have the people
who are putting on the zoning
meetings, if everyone there is a
certain age and a certain race,
then of course they're
going to only reach out
to the people who are--
or they're going to have
a natural inclination
where those people
gather and how
to outreach the people who are
the same demographic as them.
So as with most
things in life, it's
a top down diversity issue.
So if everyone in
that city office
is middle aged and white,
then it's really no surprise
that everyone who
comes to the meeting
is middle aged and white.
And that has to do with
perhaps where you're
getting your interns from.
There's just like
a wealth of ways.
It's easy to say they
need to figure out a way
to outreach to these people.
But they have to do the
work, a lot of the work
that people don't
want to do earlier.
If this is the population
I serve, why doesn't anyone
on this board look
like this population.
Thank you.
- Thank you very much
- Hi, I'm Chris.
Thank you very much for
your insightful talk
I'll have to read the book now.
So my question, I
worked for a publication
that covers data driven
policy, the use of data
to inform those residents to
serve and how to serve them.
And it seems like
the work you do,
writing fiction
can inform policy
in a much more personal way.
So I'm sort of wondering how
you think things like fiction
could be integrated
into policy and how
to balance the personal
connection to residents
or a city with things like
data that can inform policy.
- Well you know a fiction
writer doesn't ever
think their writing
is useful for anything
besides hopefully getting
people to turn the next page.
But I appreciate you saying so.
I think that one of the things
that I try to do in my fiction
is--
and that's because I
write realist fiction,
even though full
disclosure there's
a there's a ghost in
this book in the novel
so don't be alarmed
there's a ghost,
but it's still realist in my
opinion like realist fiction--
is that I really don't
try to have the answer.
I write books to answer
questions for myself.
So I have a question when
I begin to write a book
or I begin to write anything.
I don't have the answer.
And that is why
if people do think
that my book is like a good
portrait of the city of Detroit
over this many years
is because I was trying
to answer the question of why
is the house that my father grew
up in, why is it in
the state that it's in.
What does that mean?
And how do people feel about it?
And so because my
brain is not one
that was really interested
in synthesizing data
to just deliver it, I'm
interested in synthesizing data
to make a story.
I still go through some of
the same methods of inquiry.
They're not as linear.
They're a little sloppy.
They're hard to
explain to people.
But I think that one
thing that perhaps having
some more creative people be
part of that conversation can
do is get to that same point
of inquiry and exploration
without a preconceived idea.
I did not have a
million ideas about what
had happened to make
the city of Detroit
and the place my father
grew up the way that it was.
I had a few ideas.
And I actually found out that a
lot of those were not accurate.
I thought it was
really just cars.
They stopped making
cars in the city.
And so there was nothing
left in the city.
And that's not true.
When they were
still making cars,
the seeds were already
sown for the city
to end up where it was.
And so that's something
that if I was determined
to have my answer
be the correct one,
I would have never
even been receptive
to that other information.
- Thank you.
- Hi, thank you for
this presentation.
I'm Lily Song I'm a lecturer
in urban planning and design
here at the Harvard Graduate
School of Design also
a Native of a LA
ethnoburb, Cerritos.
But I wanted to ask you about--
- Cerritos auto square.
- That's right 60591.
Skate depot closed down though.
- I know it did.
- For a shopping center.
But I wanted to ask you about
the role of values and norms
guiding spatial remaking efforts
in your stories or especially
with your LA project.
So you talked about Central
Avenue and the highways.
And so I see these changes,
these mid-century era changes
is really driven by modernism,
the suburban ideal, auto
mobility.
And then now you're talking
about these recent changes
with rail and you know
all of these investments
by metro driven by the
sustainability ideal.
And urban quality of life and
connectivity and all that.
And I really appreciate
how your work
grapples with some of the
tensions and contradictions
inherent in that.
And you spoke about displacement
of communities of color
from the urban core who are the
ones predominantly taking buses
and really not owning cars.
And then they're getting pushed
out to these outlying areas
where they're now
reliant on cars.
And I wanted to
ask you if that's
a deliberate thing,
where you grapple with,
not just intergenerational
aspects within the characters
but almost
intergenerational aspects
within the cities themselves.
You know how cities change
because of these new ideas
and the zeitgeist in some ways.
- I think one thing
that's important
and that again is another
thing that I didn't really
realize probably before I became
really interested in cities
is to differentiate between
what it is a zeitgeist
and what is the priority
and norm at the time.
And where does private corporate
interests intersect in there.
So some of the things
that have happened
in Detroit as far as just
the way the city is laid out.
It has these wide grand
avenues and everyone
is spread apart from each other
because of the automobile.
Because we all
wanted to have cars
and that was part of
the middle class ideal.
But it's also because
that was the driving
industry in the city.
And so they wanted everyone
to have to need a car.
And similarly in LA,
you had families,
you had very influential
automobile connected families
that helped encourage the city
to turn their funding away
from the criss-cross of street
car lines they had before
and encouraged them more
to invest in infrastructure
like the highway system.
So it's not just--
that's one thing that I
think is hard to at the time
when it's happening especially
because we don't always
know, at the time when it
happens it does feel like we're
just all kind of galloping
forward as a culture.
But there is also
sometimes someone
who is the jockey, who's
kind of riding us forward
and who does not necessarily
have all of the residents best
interests in mind.
Whether that is
certain developers who
have this new parcel of land
and it's out here in Cerritos
and they want people
to go live in Cerritos.
And they encourage the
city to figure out a way
to get people out to Cerritos.
Or whether that is what does
like our bike-share system
look like in a city
and who is a person who
influences those decisions.
And so I think it's
both things that
have to be kind of explored
before we can really figure out
how much of it is
just where we are
and what is the
cultural influence.
- Thank you.
- Hi thank you so
much for your talk.
My name's Adam Tanaka.
I'm a graduate
student fellow here
at Radcliffe and a city
planning PhD student.
So I had a question about, do
you see any models of writers
getting involved
in policy advocacy
and how writing might play
a role in helping residents
to picture or imagine the
future of their cities.
There is a nonprofit in the
UK called Urban Woods that
actually works with communities
facing redevelopment
to basically use fiction
and poetry to engage
with policymakers and
redevelopment plans.
I don't know if you know of
any other similar models.
- I don't necessarily know
of any on a policy level that
aren't just really
focusing on literacy
or funding for the arts
or working within schools.
There's a lot of
organizations that do that.
The National Book Foundation
has an organization
called BookUp that does it.
There's an organization
called 826 that
does it throughout the country.
Or 826, I believe.
But as far as
specifically around where
people live in spaces, I know
there seem to be a lot more,
rather than being ran
by writers and poets,
they seem to be ran by other
people in the social sciences.
There's certainly a movement
to collect oral histories
and to keep heritage
sites running.
For instance, where
I live in Brooklyn
there's the Weeksville
Heritage Center,
which hosts a whole bunch
of arts related programs.
But they don't
necessarily use art
as like the forefront
of what they
do to preserve that history.
But I could just be
ignorant on that subject.
- Liz Cohen, Dean here.
I couldn't help but
want to ask a question.
Thank you for a
terrific talk first.
And I felt when I read
Turner House how deeply you
seemed to be engaging
in history and sociology
and racial politics.
But hearing you I
know that was true.
Because you've
shared that with us
today from transportation
policy to the way
the built environments develop.
So given that Turner house
is so rooted in research
into the past, I'm quite
struck by the courage
you are now about to show in
looking towards the future.
And speculating about
what you think cities
are going to look like, what
people's experiences will
be like in them.
And I wondered if
you could give us
a peek into what the cities of
Los Angeles and New York you
think will look like for
these women in their 50s.
Well, thank you.
I don't know if it's
brave or foolish.
But maybe it's brave.
And also full disclosure,
I have not read that much
since the election.
There are things I have to
work out first as far as,
Yeah, I just have to work
out a lot about will we
be able to breathe outside.
Will there be an
atmosphere for us.
But one thing that I
have been thinking about
is that not all of
my characters are
at the same place, class wise.
And that does make a
difference in the way
that their lives are lived.
And for instance,
one of my characters
moves away from LA and lives in
the Midwest and an unnamed city
and is trying to
start a movement
to create like a new kind of
Midwest urbanism that is not
reliant on the coasts.
And not in the way of
like coastal elites,
but in this is where--
I'm interested in people
who call themselves makers
and what that means.
And how that's a sort of
dangerous kind of distinction
to make.
And so she is a person
who is maker centric.
And she's like, this is
part of the country where
we make things.
And these people
don't make anything.
And she's sort of interested
in like a grassroots level.
Not necessarily seceding from
the other parts of the country,
but really she has a blog.
And she's not a good writer,
but none of her friends
tell her that because
they love her.
Where she where she kind
of explores these things.
But as far as one of the
things that I'm exploring now
is also just how
people identify.
So is this group
of women in 2015,
they would sort of
consider themselves black.
And then in 2035 that is
not necessarily the case.
And the same as how
on every census,
the options for
ethnicity change.
What are these new boxes?
And how are they negotiating
these opportunities
for recategorization?
- OK.
Have we given Angela enough of
a workout with our questions?
That was very generous to
answer so many of them.
I'd like us to thank Angela
for a wonderful talk.